بحظيرة عمي فرحات جاعت كل الحيوانات
نادته حتى يسمعها فاختلطت كل الأصوات
فاختلطت كل الأصوات
صوت البقرة موو مووو أنا جائعة يا عموو
صوت خروف ماع ماااع إنى أطلب بعض الماء
صوت دجاجة بق بق بق بيضي يفقس يتشقق
والصيصان صوصوصو تجري تقفز تتفرق
بحظيرة عمي فرحات جاعت كل الحيوانات
نادته حتى يسمعها فاختلطت كل الأصوات
فاختلطت كل الأصوات
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
هائي هائي صوت حمار كان ينادي من بالدار
نبح الكلب هاو هاو هاو ، حاول أن تصل الأخبار
صوت البطة كوااك كوااك، تسمعها فى الماء هناك
صوت القطة مياوو مياوو، اعطيني بعض الأسماك
بحظيرة عمي فرحات جاعت كل الحيوانات
نادته حتى يسمعها فاختلطت كل الأصوات
فاختلطت كل الأصوات
لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
أصوات تتعالى اسمعنا، إن يا عمي نناديك
اسرع اسرع هيا طعمنا  لو تتأخر قد نأتيك
أصوات تتعالى اسمعنا، يا عمى نناديك
أسرع أسرع هيا اطعمنا لو تتأخر قد نأتيك
بحظيرة عمي فرحات جاعت كل الحيوانات
نادته حتى يسمعها فاختلطت كل الأصوات
فأختلطت كل الأصوات